i i kind of look at you and i say here's
how tate is if somebody says well you're
wrong in this area instead of tate
saying let me explain myself people go
and push more because he found an
opportunity you know he's like let me
poke here a little bit more because it's
annoying you yeah so do you think you
have a little bit of that when you see
somebody maybe half the time like when
you said i got five wives i don't even
know if i'm convinced you want to have
five wives yeah i just think you say it
because you're pissing off the right
people yeah and that's a very astute
observation you are correct anybody you
can emotionally control anybody you can
emotionally affect
you have them in your pocket right to
one degree or another you can
emotionally control somebody i'll tell
you who's excellent at this
women
women are fantastic at this if a woman
realizes she can piss you off with x
thing she'll notice it she'll keep it in
her pocket you know what that annoys him
cool sorry baby sorry
three weeks later two months later they
they realize when you're vulnerable i
can tell you this i can take the
experience from fighting when i was
fighting
i was a kickboxing world champion right
i never made millions from fighting
kickboxing is not that big a sport 10
years ago even ufc wasn't as big as it
is now so i was making money but i mean
i was probably fighting two or three
times a year and most ever got paid was
150 grand to fight so i was kind of
normal life
and
whichever girlfriend i had at the time
no matter what she always managed to
start some asinine stupid immature fight
with me like three days before a fight
because
i'm weight drained i haven't eaten i'm
nervous i can't sleep i've been training
for [ __ ] 10 weeks this monster's from
[ __ ] kazakhstan some psycho i have to
fly over to [ __ ] [ __ ] knows where and
tishkek and bishkek to fight him and now
she's like you know in the toilet seat
i'm like
the [ __ ] toilet seat i might die he
could kill me
but she knew that's when i was weak
she knew it
and that's when you can be emotional but
they detect it this is when i can get it
right because the rest of the time i
have time to talk about the goddamn
toilet because if i say toilet seat any
other time his answer is go home
and just sit on his computer go home
then go totally at home bye no i don't
want to go home no no i actually want
you to go home please leave my house
well i didn't want to leave back goodbye
[ __ ] you next next girl so they get you
when you're weak right and anyone who
can emotionally control you and
emotionally affect you has power over
you so if i say of five wives and a
feminist goes five why dude
i'm fat i'm fat i'm fat i'll sit there
and just
yeah but obviously a lot of food needs
cooking so she needs help
and i'll just say [ __ ]
but
but that's because they make it too easy
if you're gonna give if you're playing
chess and you hang a piece
i'm gonna snap it up you're gonna leave
you're gonna leave your light hanging
thank you very much sir bam that's the
game
that's the game so yeah you're
completely right i do instigate to a
degree because they make it so [ __ ]
easy to win it's so easy for me to win
debates against people because they get
so pissed off with what i say another
thing and i'll give the game away i'll
give the game away to the entire youtube
world why i've destroyed absolutely
everybody in any debate ever i say
things that they know are true and that
they agree with but i say in a way that
angers them emotionally and they get
caught up in their brain because they're
saying he's saying the truth but i'm
pissed off by how he's saying it so i
want to argue with him but he's right
so instead of saying
men are physically stronger than women
i'll say females are weak
females are weak well females a week
females are weak men are strong females
are weak
no females but i'm right and he knows
i'm right but he's mad now and so is she
and they sit there and you will happen
happened on dave portnoy you end up
having a whole group of people sitting
there trying to argue well some women
are strong like men trying to argue the
fact that women are the strongest men
physically because i've emotionally
controlled them all and upset them all
and then i do a podcast i get billions
and millions of views and unlimited
likes against good debaters like dave
and his little crew by just emotionally
controlling them it's an emotional game
i reckon i've never given this game away
before anywhere but this is what i do i
sit there and i say something they know
is true in a way they can't agree with
it and i [ __ ] control them all
because they're stupid if i was me i'd
be like yeah okay perhaps i don't like
the way you phrased it but you're very
you're very true that takes intellect
people are emotional so this is why i
wreck all of them and you're right i
poke them on purpose and it makes it
very difficult to argue with me
especially if they agree with what i'm
saying but they don't like the way it's
being said that's where you see the full
breakdown it's the full mental breakdown
if you enjoyed this video and you want
to watch the entire podcast click over
here and if you want to be connected
with experts influencers such as
kiyosaki tate connolly parliamentary
myself and others download the app
minect where you get a chance to connect
with these folks by the minute you get
to buy the minute or have face times
with them 15 minutes ask them any
questions you may want to have download
the app connect and start connecting
with influencers and experts today
[Music]